hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Olli crap welcome to
let's play Kuro Oni now a lot of you
have been suggesting and I've kind of
been avoiding it you guys have been
suggesting this game called Ione and I
am you know I look at those RPG maker
horror games and I'm like I look at him
I go well well you know I could part of
me goes I should give every game a
chance but a part of me goes it just
seems really silly but anyway so this is
actually a 3d version of Ionia I believe
that's made in the Unity engine so let's
see how to play press right mouse button
to pick up objects and open doors press
escape to save current game you can't
save your game while you're being hunted
down good to know so you can't escape if
you're being hunted by whatever let's go
let's get this over with
whoa actually looks pretty nice
obviously the Unity engine Wow look at
that bump mapping are anyway so
obviously the Uni engine's gonna make
things look pretty good generally I mean
it has what's it what just happened oh
well oh I went into this okay oh I see
it so when you go into a room you
actually go into the room okay yeah okay
I've never actually played or seen Ione
so or seen a playthrough of Ione I mean
so I mean I've seen it obviously but
I've never seen a full playthrough of it
so I don't know if this is like
mimicking the layout of the house or
something or what or if it's like I'm
supposed to know something about this
said I'm not hello I just turn that bow
hello what's down there hang on let me
dump dump dump okay let's go do I have a
flashlight no I do not
whoa blood on the ground
boxes barrels bookshelves what's down
here now monster
I got a bad
about this Murdoch
[Music]
yeah how about you go to hell yeah man I
do not like this place
yeah this place give me the creeps
there's not even like a music that ah
dark hallway I thought I saw something
yeah did you guys see something I
thought I saw something yeah oh no it's
just my read my reticle is red oh okay I
get it man I do not like that hallway
wide like this even less was this it is
like some indentation on the wall here
thump thump thump thump thump thump
what's the deal
oh here we go what I found some wood
yeah yay what am I gonna do about that
what is this on no no huh what click on
the box to insert the code what I can't
I can't click on these I can't even see
them they're washed out what is going on
here oh okay I get it
wait one I hang on I'm trying to
[Applause]
after enters face control there's
something behind me in there
well [ __ ] what is this I can't do
anything
was it a bug hum oh okay save and
continue' okay do that jeez what the
hell was that all about had me worried
okay
yeah I couldn't even see and it's like
one two three three four five six seven
eight zero nine got too many threes
there okay so I don't know maybe once I
get the pattern in or punch the code in
like one of these walls will open up or
I don't know oh this game is so quiet oh
that's not a good thing not a good thing
I don't even know what I'm what I'm
afraid of cuz I haven't even seen a
monster besides that oh oh hello
what are you i stick some wood in you
I've got wood wood okay so I need to go
to another part of the house to find a
code if that was part of the original
game that I have no idea what I'm doing
so I went behind the secret bookshelf
without actually finding much else in
the game so I'm guessing if there's a
lot of stuff here that I don't know
about there's something else in this
room that I needed nope okay move in
this way some in here that I need new Oh
boom aha see
it's an empty envelope what do I need an
empty envelope for not shut up music go
away you're not gonna do anything to me
you don't have the balls to do anything
to me I'm Way too brave and awesome
library key whoo library huh
where was there a library I mean that
place had more bookshelves than anything
else
look here know the store on the left was
locked right can't sprint so this is the
only speed of I dunno maybe it's this
door down here could be sorry excuse me
ah man I don't know when I will know if
I'm being hunted ah that was the library
door okay so what have we got here oh
it's a library some behind these some
some pop outta me he's something going
to try to surprise me
no aha what are you ah you look like a
lever for that thingy should I go back
now okay
guessing I should so I'm gonna happen
nothing's happening and that's worrying
me more than anything else shut up shut
up
where was it only one way shut up shut
up wait where is that lever I don't
remember it was in the basement that's
right oh whoa yeah that was
he was in the room on the right wasn't
it I don't know I don't remember shut up
[Applause]
shut up shut up shut up side of OHS over
here I don't remember
aha blump what did that do what I do it
do anything all right
no what does that do what did that do
did it long unlocked oh maybe I unlock
one of the yeah horrifying door away
always man God if I wasn't recording
this I don't think I could keep moving
forward in this game this isn't gaming
like freaking me out and nothing's
happened okay
well what's the dealio what the hell did
I do there's like no evidence of
anything actually happening in these
games so I can't tell if I'm doing
something right or wrong so oh well
whatever let's just get moving
oh I just want to know when the hell I'm
being hunted let me save and continue'
here cuz maybe I'll ah come on don't do
that to me don't flip me around when I
need to go in a specific direction one
will one mind one door okay so that
lever did it it didn't open anything
there ergo you must self open something
here aha nothing no nothing nothing in
the library those doors it's hardened oh
no what anything does what did that
lever do did that lever even do anything
did I actually pull on the lever
I tried right-clicking on it after the
fact but it didn't seem to help it at
all what am i doing what's going on
bang bang bang help me I'm stuck in a
house with no idea of what I'm doing so
I'm in the library maybe it's gonna in
circles at this point huh
wait was that
oh those this painting down nevermind
get this envelope here okay I do
anything with this new maybe it'll
reveal a secret message when held up
against something important
maybe yeah do some now gonna actually do
something
no that's what I thought nothing brave
for you okay now I've tried every door
so what am I supposed to do I don't have
a combination for the keypad that's the
only other thing that I could think
about it's gotta be some down here
because obviously the levers here so why
wouldn't the whatever the lever of sex
be down here as well I don't know I
don't often question these things huh
lever was in then let me just double
check make sure I actually Oh what the
hell how'd you get up again you weren't
supposed to get up you're supposed to be
down okay I don't know I can't do
anything about it's just it's not it's
not polo bowl
I'm spamming my clicker meter all over
it and it's not doing anything so I
don't know maybe I don't know I don't
know it's confusing what is that some I
can't even Crouch envelope envelope
envelope envelope envelope envelope I
don't know
I don't know anything down this hallway
Oh nope screw you screw you screw you
and everything you care about big
[Applause]
what's the code
what's the code maybe that's 1 1 2 3 3 4
5 6 7 8 yeah 0 9 - enter No Boop
ah I don't know
I'm uh I'm not a bit of a loss here
there's nothing in this envelope
maybe there was something like on one of
the bookshelves in the library I don't
know I don't know I mean we've already
covered that I am an idiot they're gone
I can't solve any of these puzzles for
myself but but don't know what to do
about this what am i doing was that hmm
there's something behind me there's some
standing right behind me in there okay I
don't know I don't know have a letter by
the power of papyrus ibis oh ah come on
those I looked there before I saw okay
so moving forward I have a key for the
first floor
hi described as a male boss Oh
[Applause]
oh crap did you see that it was the
thing for the menu oh man terrifying
I shouldn't look back I should not have
looked back I'm a bad habit doing that
oh man I guess I'd go out there's a bad
place to hide I hear it I hear it out
there my phone died might be boned and
safe because I'm being hunted right huh
hi what's going on oh oh damn it game
crashed Oh
game cast game crash sorry I'm coming
back in I'm gonna I'm gonna give this a
better do better next time don't run
straight in the eye here we go you're
coming out and three two one Oh Oh is it
recording good yeah oh no oh no oh no oh
good Oh it did save me here good good
good good good good
hopefully you guys can see this
hopefully it's recording correctly ah
good good good good that means that
means we can go and instead of going
somewhere I think the first floor keep
might be the double door so I'm gonna go
for them next after I grab the key
before I go out I'm gonna save again so
there if it gets me again
then I don't have to go as far okay so
hop I do Lulu I don't know what the hell
that was it did not look like a thing
that I've seen from Ione I don't even
know what that means what does Kuro only
mean anyway okay here we go come on me
bro come on oh it's not here
oh good that was wrong anyway
oh yeah hi are you okay ah no ah hello
my hand the game crash hmm where's where
is there a locked door down there maybe
the door on the right side the right
side I'm not exactly sure not exactly
sure anyway
huh let me think about this hmm
yeah I'll stop it here it's been over 50
minutes so I'll stop it here all right
I'll figure this out and then I'll do
another I'll do another video this
because it just got really interesting
with the Edit with the addition to that
monster so thank you all so much for
watching if you want to play for
yourself obviously the Lincoln isn't is
in the description below if it's not
there call me out on that [ __ ] call me
an idiot so alright so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
[Music]
go that darn battle phone
[Music]